listen we just
we're talking too because i think that
everybody's waiting for you and jay-z to
work together ever since the roc nation
thing
yeah there they are everybody was
everybody was thinking hov was going to
be on burton or proof
i was saying it in the comments i'm like
yo i hate to let the people down when i
especially when you put the tape over
the name
when you drop them because the big sean
verse happened i didn't
i heard that record without sean on it
so that sean verse is rather recent
right
yup yup yup yeah cause hit boy played me
that record and just had wayne on it
people just knew it was whole i kind of
think people knew
i mean i kind of think like we knew
people was going to think that so that's
why there's like yo tape the name
put the tape on it let's let's troll the
fans like we played into that
yeah for sure um is that something that
like obviously everybody wants to do a
song with jay-z
everybody does um you have a direct line
with hove like you but you also don't
want to be the guy that just
asks for the verse you kind of want it
to just happen yeah of course i wanted
to just happen but i'm not going to lie
i act as a big homie for the first
because it's like you cannot like not
ask for the first still like you got to
let them know like yo you know what i
mean but
it's something that was gonna happen i
was saying this if i was to get a whole
verse
i would be the the person who got one
the quickest
hope don't hand verses out like that and
he don't hand them out that quick
when people get a whole verse you're
already a legend
solidified in the game by the time you
get the verse nine times out of ten
and i'm not at that point yet you know
what i'm saying maybe
i don't know you know what i'm saying
maybe i don't know i know i know that he
want to do it because we spoke about it
yeah but
is the time is the time right maybe not
facts